Okay. So, um we are doing a special
session of this class called Me the
students. Now, um I've been overwhelmed
by the positive response online on
YouTube. So, thank you so much for uh
watching this channel and leaving
comments and subscribing. I I really
appreciate it. It's such positive
feedback for the work I do. So, um
there's been a lot of questions online
about this class and who I am. So, I'm
gonna do two separate videos. The first
video is I'm going to introduce you to
my students, Ekko, Amber, and City. And
then in another video, I'm going to talk
about myself. Okay? But this video is
really about um my students and their
impressions of this class and how it has
benefit benefited them. Um I I'm not I'm
not free to tell uh people what the
school is, okay? Because this is in
China and um there are certain things I
say in this are sensitive. So I do not
want to get my school into trouble. So
we will not mention the school um in
this video but uh my students will tell
you about their impressions of taking
this class. Okay. So um my first
question is for SI. Now SI was my class
not this year but last year. So last
year uh there's a different uh version
of this class where the first semester I
taught the great books, second semester
I taught geopolitics.
Okay. and city has an interesting
background because you were in Germany
for a few years, right? And your father
is professor of Emanuel Pant at Chinua.
So, so you've you've encountered um this
sort of teaching before. Okay. So, um u
my first question to you is let's talk
about the great books. U what what were
your favorite great books and why were
they such and why did you enjoy them so
much? Um can you speak to the mic
please?
So um two of the most memorable books I
can think of are the Iliad and Dantis
Inferno. Um I really like the Iliad
already before the class where I had uh
read a simpler version u since it's a
really popular book and um there's been
many adaptations over the years but uh
in this class was the first time I
really um more in depth looked into the
content of it. Uh and I think that this
class provided me a lot of new insights
into um the book and the kind of
different backgrounds especially also
into um the culture of the time with the
kings and small kingdoms and cities and
things like that.
I remember afterwards we had also looked
taking a look at the Inyad. Uh the Inyad
being of course um from the Roman period
uh a very different period uh which also
took inspiration from the Indiad. Uh and
it was really interesting seeing the
contrasting uh cultures of both the
Greek and the Roman uh culture.
Especially uh with in this class I I I
had already encountered the Iniad as
well before but in this class we also
talked about how much the Inyad was
taken as a propaganda piece uh at the
time. Uh so that was also really
interesting to see. And with the Dantis
Inferno um I had heard about it uh quite
many times before but I never really had
uh the chance to look into it. So I was
really happy when we uh decided to start
reading it and uh taking such an
in-depth look into specific parts of the
book uh was really really fun. Um so I
want to ask you about these books how
they change your understanding of
yourself and your relationship with the
world do you think?
uh so a few key theories uh ideas that I
remember from uh last year that the idea
of game theory and the idea of
imagination. So in both of uh both the
uh all three of these books um the idea
of uh imagination uh is really
important. For example, with the Ilia, I
remember it was uh one of the first like
big works of imagination that we really
have. Uh where it developed imagination
over the times afterwards a lot with um
such a vivid description of a story. Uh
it really um pushed people to the limits
of what they could imagine and it really
changed them. Uh so it was really
interesting uh learning about that and
uh it definitely changed uh my view on
how uh people perceive the world around
them and how we for ourselves for
example have very different perceptions
from everyone our around us. Uh of
course there's also the idea of game
theory where um everyone does things u
according to certain uh situations and
conditions that uh they face and it
really like helps you think about why
certain people do something and uh why
certain conditions exist. Yeah. Um, so
is it fair to say that reading these
books have made you more curious about
the world and have made you more
observant about the world around you?
Um, yeah, I would definitely say that um
it's made me more curious. Um, I've
already initially had a big interest in
uh literature and ancient history. Um,
so these books kind of respsparked this
enthusiasm of learning more about it.
Uh, I afterwards also looked a bit more
uh these books uh myself and even looked
into a bit uh surrounding uh books. Uh
so it was really uh helpful in like
expanding my horizon in this topic.
Okay, thanks so much. So Ekko and Amber
are in my class this year and this year
we did something crazy and insane which
is we just the entirety of human
history, right? We went from the ice age
up to today which is the American
Empire. So um um I want to ask you both.
Okay, Ekko and Ember. The first question
is, how do you feel about
history now that we've covered all the
major um episodes of human history? And
second of all, how has learning history
changed your understanding of the world
we live in today? Okay. So, these are
two big questions. You can answer one or
both.
Um, yeah. For the first question, um, I
think this has really um gave me a lot
of insights on was like how there are
things certain things that we take for
granted that are kind of changed or
challenged in this course. Like for
instance, I remember the very first
class that we did was on like how
humanity transitioned from like uh
hunter gatherer to a an agricultural
society. And so that idea of the
agricultural society being more stable
is like kind of modern view this issue
that we often take for granted. But like
what we learned from this class is that
religion actually has a lot of influence
on this transition like how setting down
was like um really beneficial for
practicing religions and rituals and as
a huge factor that shaped this
transition. So I think my understanding
of history has been challenged quite a
lot of ways in this course in terms of
It challenges me to think deeper into
the things that we view from a modern
society or like a view that we take for
granted.
Great. Thanks. So, thank you. Thank you.
Okay. My turn. Um I think for the first
question, what is uh the history that we
learned from this class? I think firstly
is that uh for for for the education
except for like middle school or
something else. um history is more like
about what happened before and simply uh
the events the time the person and but I
think in this course it's more like an
intersectionality between the politics
economic and u uh civilization culture
stuff like this and uh actually when you
see the complexity of the civilization
and also uh what I want to also credit
to echo was saying is that a very very
important insight from this history
class is
uh the power of religion or saying
that's not maybe particular a religion
with ritual with uh doctrine but more
like how belief is impact to to the
people to the community to the society
and also uh to talking about what
changed my mind I think a very important
part is that history is not linear
sometimes is that not being like always
being improved and actually more about
uh people's will belief their choice
situation and uh and let me think about
like especially I want to talk about
your
uh like u I think significant class is
about the empire is that you mentioned
about like uh we learn from the death we
learn from the past we learn from the
mistakes we have made so I think from
from this point point of view, I'm more
thinking about like history is like a
book about making mistake and we learn
from the experience instead of to say
that history has always been grand
excellence and
great thank you. Thank you so much.
Okay. So, um, great. Thank you so much.
My next question is,
um, I want you to reflect and think back
to this course, this one year, okay? And
tell me
at one po at what point
um, what did I say or what did I teach
you that was like most shocking to you?
And when you heard it, you were like you
were kind of stunned or shocked. And
this is
Do do you have a moment like this during
this course when I said something you're
like this is just completely shocking
and to me okay how you echo yeah like
for me um that goes back to the class
where we talk about religion um one idea
that you mentioned was like people are
like all human beings are fundamentally
religious and that was like quite
shocking because like for me I I I kind
of like I don't personally believe in
any religion and I I kind of um
reflecting on like my own life, religion
seems like pretty far away and like it's
quite um quite being denied by our
society right now. And like by learning
about the history of like the the Greeks
and like the Romans and all that kind of
stuff, like what I realized is that um
the most creative societies were those
that praised the poets and all those
like theaters the most. And and that's
like um how the great celebrated um
Homer and like um that that's really the
part that makes us human.
And so going back to the idea of being
religious, that idea is kind of denied
in this modern society which values
rationality over these fundamental
aspects that makes us human. And so like
we read part of the the poems and like
literatures and that really makes me
that like resonates with me in terms of
like after such a long time in history
but that connection and emotion that we
share as human beings are just um
irreplaceable. Great. Thank you so much
uh Amber.
Um I like very agree with what Echo said
because religion religious belief is
very important have lots of percentage
in our course and uh one argument is
very insightful for me during the
classes uh that people actually
sometimes want to live in the dream
instead of to face the reality. I think
this actually explains a lot of uh my
like confused to like my confusion to to
to the past forcing to to my life in
other aspects. And also
uh like another another point is that
when you talk about lots of like
celebrity in the history, you think you
will state that there are sometimes
their logic is to make them become the
gods. This is also a kind of like a very
very new way to interpret these people's
and strategies because as EO said we are
live in China we don't have like a very
united religious belief so these stuff
are usually being like far from our life
but from such kind of like a lecture I
think it actually let me know more about
um even though we seemingly to transform
to like modern society we're actually
still using a lot of uh the experience
from the past we are still credits or
respect to the history even sometimes
we're not
Yeah. So um you said something really
important. Okay. I want to paraphrase
what you said, but the idea that you
present is maybe in China we are too
utilitarian
and so that prevents us from achieving
greatness. But if you look at all the uh
people we've studied before like
Napoleon
um they achieve greatness because they
want to be they want to like be God.
They they had faith in themselves and
they they they they were achieving these
grand visions. And maybe in China we we
lack these sort of people. We lack that
sort of spirit. Okay.
Um so what I can directly think of when
thinking of shocking ideas is that uh
when we were reading the inad um through
through the whole reading of it, I
actually thought it was quite a nice
book. Uh uh and contrary to what uh I
ended up on um throughout the book, it
seemed uh pretty normal for me. But at
the very uh in the very last lesson
about I remember that um you told us
about how it's actually a piece of
propaganda from the Romans to uh implant
these ideas of um duty and uh things
like that into the uh readers minds or
the audience's minds and right there and
then I like realized a lot of the things
are truly were happening throughout the
entire book where for example uh the
main character uh just has this
motivation of for the greater good
instead of for himself which loses him
his personality in this uh in his
pursuit of these goals and I think it's
really important of uh these things
where we um in the beginning don't don't
see past like certain ways of propaganda
if you would say so uh and I think uh it
really was a very shocking moment for me
where I realized like throughout this
entire period of reading this book it
was right in front of our eyes but
because it was so well hidden it was
just so hard to notice so it was a
really really big part that I still
remember today Okay, great. Thank you so
much. So, um, as a teacher, um, I just
feel so gratified that you've enjoyed
this course and but also I can see that
it's changed all of you for the better.
It's made you more curious. It's made
you more observant. It's made you more
critical. Uh, it's it's and you're able
to take these ideas and reflect back on
on your society around on society around
you and question it further. Okay, which
is which was my objective to begin with.
So I feel extremely gratified. Thank you
so much. Okay. Now another question is
there's lots of people online who are
just curious. You guys are turning
students. You're actually training
students. Uh city is going to Germany
for university. Amber and Echo are going
to America. So um people people want
want to hear you are the future of
China. What are your plans? What do you
want to study university? What what what
what do you want to do after university?
How do you see your career trajectory
and your life trajectory? Okay. So maybe
maybe we'll start with Echo.
like I'm I'm going to cos college at the
United States. So if you're card say hi.
Okay.
Yeah. Like um and this is September and
um I applied as like an undecided major
because I want to explore more
especially like history, sociology and
like maybe psychology and all kinds of
areas because like especially in this
class what I think it's really is that
you took multiple perspectives in like
viewing um history as a whole like how
geopolitics impact like um this
historical development and like um some
of the psychological aspects as well as
a lot of like interconnected
disciplines. So I really wanted to um
explore more about them. So I I not sure
what my major would be. Poor cancer.
Poor cancer.
Um I'm going to New York University for
liberal studies. So say hi to say hi to
New York City.
Um so so liberal uh the program I apply
is basically about the all about liberal
arts and humanitiz. So I have already
like registered for courses about like
antiquity and uh writing and also
history and politics. So this class is
actually preparation for Yes.
Definitely. for college. Yeah. And for
for for future plan um actually
I don't know because I haven't
participated to the college yet. So but
definitely um I will still want to do
something for my hometown and society
and whatever because I'm uh besides uh
like a fan of history I'm also like a
feminist and they all know that. So I
might might do something like for
feminism like gender studies and also uh
with like history and humanitiz. I think
this is the part that we are currently
not very valuable or encouraged in
Chinese society and I hope it can be
light again. Great. Thank you. Um so I'm
um thinking of going back to Germany. Um
well since applications aren't uh
finished yet I'm not quite sure where
I'll be going but it's probably in the
state of uh button woodenburg um I am
planning on either studying history or
philosophy. Um I I think I'm going to
likely pursue it as far as I can maybe
into a PhD. Um and uh for future plans I
am it's it's going to be a long time
still so I'm not that sure yet but um I
am hoping that uh since culture and uh
education is very different from China
uh to Europe and especially Germany. Um
and I think it's important to have a
combination of cultures um to be able to
see things from very different
perspectives. So I possibly will return
to China uh with like the knowledge I've
gained in Europe. And it's not more it's
not really about imposing western ideas
on Chinese society but rather a
combination of it. And maybe it will
help with um having more different views
on uh society and different issues.
Okay, great. So fantastic. Okay. Um I
mean just hearing your answers I know
all three of three of you will be very
successful in university and you will
achieve all that you aim for. You guys
are smart um observant
um hardworking you guys are going to be
very successful in life. All right so I
have complete faith in all three of you.
Okay. Um my last question okay and um
it's a hard question and feel free you
don't have to answer it. Okay. But I
want to ask you this question. Um
because I think a lot of people online
are just curious. Um
how do you see the state of the world
and society today? And you you you talk
about the world in general, you talk
about America, you talk about China.
Okay. But what are some issues and
concerns that you have about what's
happening in what what's happening in
China? What's happening in the world?
What's happening in United States? Okay.
So you don't have to answer this
question because I and it's a hard
question but does anyone want to um try?
Sure. So um looking at current politics
uh which is uh very complex at the
moment uh but I feel like there's a lot
of um similarities to what has happened
in the past. I haven't taken this year's
um class, but I'm uh it's I feel like
it's similar to what I've heard uh where
history teaches a lesson about uh things
to us. And I think that um for example,
right now there's a lot of similarities
to what has happened previously in the
buildup to certain uh conflicts in the
world. Uh and I think that it is
important for us to be able to recognize
these patterns of where conflict is on
the horizon and to either decide to
change things a bit to prevent these or
to approach these conflicts in a better
way because um for example with the u
politics currently in the US uh or the
politics over here in Asia um there's a
lot of power relationships that are uh
similar to uh both the start of World
War I and World War
and the conditions during the cold war
uh which of course have been in the past
century uh but it's still the same uh
different political ide kind of similar
political ideologies uh allying with
each other and kind of having this
rivalry on a global stage with each
other. So I think it's really important
to recognize these patterns being surf
surfacing again and with the increase in
conflicts globally I think it's really
important that we uh as a society watch
out to what is happening right now. Um
so um one thing I taught you uh last
year that you've internalized is the
idea that there are there are structures
and forces to the movement of politics
geopolitics and if we study these
structural forces we have a better
understanding of what's happening but
also we can better influence what's
happening. So so thank you. Okay. Um do
you any of you also want to comment
um how you read the world? Yeah. Like
what are issues that you're that concern
you about the world today or in the
society today? Because you talk about
feminism. So um what is about about
China you think that you're concerned
about and you want to focus more about
in in the future society and the world.
Um I think one thing I actually observed
from this course is also a side that
more brutal than I thought before. So um
but also also as we have mentioned in
the class I think civilization is a
cycle. It's like we are I think there's
no need to be too worried about uh the
world or the politics because we are
always in a like a point of the natural
cycle we uh we're in the process and I
think we definitely can learn something
for saying that ask for
from the past from history. So that's I
think the also the meaning of continue
learning and uh talking about feminism
um I
I curious about such topic more from my
family and actually not about the lots
of like big picture. So uh I think
for for the world is sometimes I should
firstly focus on individual focus on my
own heart and I find the answer of
myself and then to interact with the
world and to um as and also as for China
I think the social issue
I think is we are firstly we are lack of
a belief maybe not particularly about
the religion but I feel sometimes people
are very lost and the second one is that
I think uh
we still want to live in the queen so
how to let the people more trying to
wake up and face the reality. I think
it's a quite
like difficult mission that we need to
explore in the future. Okay. So, uh
Ember, I want to thank you because I've
heard two things. Okay. Um the first
thing is by taking this course, um even
though history is depressing, you still
feel empowered because you feel like the
answers lie in history. If we can study
history deep enough, we can understand
the present. We can impact the present
positively. So, so even though a lot of
things we discussed in this class are
extremely pessimistic and depressing,
you still have it still gave you a power
a sense of like individual empowerment
and agency. Okay, I mean that's the
first thing. Second thing is um I think
taking this course um and maybe some
other factors as well but you feel as
though that you as an individual can
have a positive impact on society if you
engage in a process of deep learning for
yourself and then a process of educating
others. So so so that's what I heard.
Okay. But but but thank you. Okay. Uh
Echo.
Yeah. Like for me um one of the problems
or like issues that I that I am
personally pretty concerned with is
education and China because like
currently we live in a highly um
rational and eilitarian society.
And so like especially in like
international schools as well as um
traditional high schools in China,
people like take a lot of tests and like
do a lot of like um recite a lot of
stuff and things like that and and that
kind of um diminish the part where
people feel that connection with the
reality. And so what I've learned from
this course is that when we um discuss a
unit about the Vikanian society so One
thing that I uh that's pretty impressive
to me is that the Vikings spent like a
third of their wealth on like a funeral.
And so what does what does that mean is
that like they value their society
values a lot about stories that they
pass from generation to generations. And
that emotional part was kind of
diminished by the utilitarianism in our
current world. So I think um especially
for my personal experience courses like
um like like this one and and like study
of history has been kind of um devalued
in this um especially when technologies
and like science like the dominant trend
and I'm not saying that this is bad or
anything but it's like it kind of makes
us internalize
that there are certain problems that we
really want to look into and people
don't really realize especially
um yeah okay so um echo I think no
matter what you do in life you're going
to be a very passionate educator and it
could be a professor it could be a
researcher it could be a teacher doesn't
matter okay but I think like just
hearing you speak your students are
going to um love love you and you're
going to have a huge impact on your
students okay so so thank you all right
So um for me this was a fantastic
conversation because this is actually
the first time this year I've had a
chance to talk to students get some
feedback. So I feel extremely gratified.
I thank all all three of you and I hope
that we can stay in touch and I think
that for um uh my YouTube audience this
was actually extremely enlightening
because now for the first time they can
see uh my students and they can see uh
what Chinese students are like and and
and I and I think people on YouTube are
will be very impressed by all three of
you and I hope that we can stay in touch
and maybe we can do a follow-up session
a year from now or two years from now
when we're back in Beijing together and
have a chance to ask you about your
university experience and how this
course has prepared for you for
university. So, thanks so much uh and
we'll stay in touch. Okay. Okay. Thank
you. Bye.